[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we have
with us colleen lionheart
currently off the record so we're going
to take this time and talk about popular
misconceptions
about what men think make them
attractive
you know be funny if or let's we should
do it this way like guys
say what they think
makes guys attractive and clean can
answer if that's actually true or not
totally smoke us i could i could say one
thing okay because i speak for all women
well you believe all women sorry clearly
i could say once or twice
that you don't even got to tell me
because i know now
but
when i was like 15 years old i swore to
god
if i had an exhaust on my civic
and i was like
oh dude and if i [ __ ] try to like
screech across the street i thought all
the chicks were getting hella horn
so i was like oh [ __ ] these chicks are
gonna be [ __ ] hitting me
all the tips are like what's an exhaust
[Laughter]
you exhaust me
all the things that attract guys
guys do that thinking that girls would
like it like getting a sports car or
whatever when you end up getting a
sports car most
most attention comes from men
or gold diggers but mostly men
i remember when i was um
a kid i really thought that girls love
to watch me wrestle my friends
if i had a crush right i'm dominant i'm
the
dan honestly that's kind of how the
truth is so true
you would always do that in front of the
girls elementary school
and but you know what it was funny it
was like a um
it was like an unwritten rule amongst
guys in elementary school like when you
just had pretty girls like sitting on
the bench and you just like for some
reason you just start [ __ ] wrestling
your friends and laughing some guys
never grow out of it
we do it all the time
aren't we attractive the best thing in
the world is when they notice they're
watching and they start laughing mm-hmm
and then because you're you're just kind
of like oh they like that you feel like
you sold at home or something you're
like yeah yeah sealed the deal
laughter my version of that maybe when i
was like
maybe when i was like uh probably
elementary school between seven and
maybe ten
is
going hella fast on my bike because
there was a girl that lived like a
little bit down the street i thought she
was cute and i would see them play so
i'm like oh just i'm just casually
riding down the street and then when i
know that i'm in their peripheral vision
i go like this
and then you know those little curves
and i'm like
she didn't see
around
nothing like that just trying to like i
think you're trying to peacock right
like you're trying to like get there
yeah you're trying to but you're like
damn bar got some air on that i should
ask him how many times has that worked
where she is peddles faster catch up to
you like what you just did
oh my
god i'm in
amazing the other kid on the street just
go like walk up to her like
what's that you're playing oh skip it or
whatever and then skip it
they're just having a conversation
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i think um
one one thing that i thought was uh
growing up was like this is for years
that that girl would like his like
looks like so like you know you know
what you know so guys
we were really attracted to physical
like girls hair face bodies whatever
right guys are really visual so then so
then you think that girls would want the
same thing and i think that's where like
where dudes get the idea of sending dick
pics and stuff is because you want to
see
ladies private parts too so you think oh
man she probably wants equitable trade
i must be i never die
if i can think of what a [ __ ] high
schooler's thinking of that's probably
what they're thinking of right
so like for me all i was thinking about
was like man
what is the body part that girls like
the most so i would ask all of my um
female friends like what do you what
what do you like in a guy and they start
talking about stupid things like
personality i'm like no
like what body part you can't take a
picture of that yeah yeah
you said all those horrible photos
some girls be like shoulders somebody's
like oh i really like the chest or like
i like abs your left elbow
got it
so when i heard that
that's all i focused on it's just like
let me get let me just [ __ ] get the
biggest shoulders yeah and i [ __ ]
failed because i got tired and i didn't
know how to work out
because you ate the brownie you went to
the gym and
offered you brownie i think a lot of
guys still probably think that's like oh
my body my body like girls like bodies
because i like bodies they must like
bodies i did that this girl told me she
liked uh
the collarbone or like that that part so
this is like back when american apparel
is like popping dvds
now it talks to her like this
try to flex it and try to stick it out
you just stick your neck out yeah i try
to stick my collarbone out but instead i
just look like an
idiot and i think what was unsexy was
the fact that like
you know when she mentioned that she
didn't mean that i wanted she wanted me
to tether my whole [ __ ] satisfaction
over that being noticed that just made
it unsexy so i was like [ __ ]
women i also think that it was like
really clear i would i would i would
hear ladies talk about how uh they want
a guy that's funny yeah right somebody
who makes them laugh but if you aren't
like really good at being funny um you
end up not being somebody to laugh with
but somebody to laugh at and then that
sometimes is actually not very sexy yeah
no yeah you don't understand so then uh
i remember in high school i was easier
to laugh at than with for a period of
time still till this damn is that is
that true
like literally look at you
i got fashion what do you think of that
laughing at or with
which one do you prefer
my
relationship ended because i couldn't
connect with him in that in that way
oh on the humor way
like your humor was so important my
humor it was like i had humor he didn't
what
how long did you guys uh six months six
also you guys were just testing it out
and then six months you're like man we
just don't connect that way yeah i think
like during that six months i was in
denial i'm like i mean this could work
i'll make it work yeah because there are
other factors that we we enjoyed
obviously but that i realize that's a
really big factor for me to connect with
somebody i mean because humor is like a
form of intelligence like it's it's that
weird banter that you know
yeah absolutely it is but too bad you're
not funny though because i think like
comedians as modern-day philosophers
right yeah because you could you see
different perspectives but most people
don't right so i'm like that's pretty
good it's not meant for everybody to
catch people that think very linear or
they can't see the comedy or the joke or
maybe they're just too literal right
yeah
that's really the curse there the
literal part cause when they when they
hear the joke or when they hear comedy
they just think it's so below them
because they're like that's so stupid
and they write it off but it's like
but you don't [ __ ] see the nuance the
subtext double entendre like you're not
looking at these and then you look at
them like do you have asperger's what
the [ __ ]
all the spatulas they just go no i don't
that's insensitive
the [ __ ] way um did he did you ever
tell him that prior and did he try to
make an effort to sort of connect with
you um no because it's just not his uh
it just wasn't his character it's just
not who he was so it says like why try
to change somebody like here's a joke
book
study better
study jokes get him classes at ucb i
expect by dinner to laugh five times
[Laughter]
stressing
he's all trying to memorize these
knock-knock jokes you give him a mic
go ahead all right make me laugh funny
guys
knock knock that's the [ __ ] word dude
make me laugh
like oh dude you're funny hey make us
laugh is there um
like dudes like what do you think is one
of the
biggest like when dudes are going
fishing for chicks right like what's one
of the worst
baits that they use
like girls need i mean guys need to just
stop doing this name dropping oh it's a
good one is it because is it is it
hollywood specific that's a good one
dropping is like an instant checked out
yeah that's a good check so that's why
that's why right when nick was like oh
you know marley or whatever you're like
man [ __ ] this fool i was like [ __ ] no
that's a good one because brother
because brad pitt was telling me this is
the same [ __ ] you should
yeah first name
brad even with dudes though
you know what you mean dudes and they're
like that too oh yeah i'll just give uh
you know just eating breakfast steven
spielberg's house and it was crazy yeah
it's name dropping or flaunting like
fancy in your area you're like yeah
assets i'm not talking physically i'm
talking about like your actual like
yeah yeah how much you lost and luna
this table is done
this is the luna table we are out of the
game
yeah dude
37 luna dude that's especially true for
like i feel like with colleen like
because they know she's part of an
industry then they're a lot of guys are
probably thinking which names are going
to impress her yeah i was a key group
for uh students
i was best boy
i was the best boy
i'm not familiar i'm not familiar
it's right in between dolly grip
oh
i wonder why people do that today's
video is brought to you by audible all
right you know these days it's difficult
for me to sit down and actually read a
book especially with my add i'm like
looking at one sentence and before you
know it i'm in the backyard gardening
there's so many things i want to like
learn and get to know but with all of
these books that are like slapping me in
the face i don't even know how i could
get through one but thanks to audible i
realized i am a
ear learner which is an audible learner
and so i pull up the books that i get
and i just listen to him and it doesn't
matter if i'm doing kung fu in the
backyard or i'm throwing rocks at a tree
no matter where i am in the world i can
continuously listen to a book and finish
it that's pretty cool and for a lot of
people i think listening is the best way
because that helps me out too i remember
even back in college like i would read
the textbook but actually what helped me
out the most was recording the lecture
in class
and so what's cool about audible is they
have all kinds of stuff they don't just
have audio books they also have uh
audible originals they even have
podcasts they have a whole wide range of
entertainment for your audio needs yup
and right now i'm listening to marcus
aurelius meditations you see that right
here there's my audible
for such persons it is natural that
these things should occur
damn put you straight to sleep some
people want to learn but for me i use
that to help me relax that's dope so let
audible help you discover new ways to
laugh be inspired or be entertained new
members can try it free for 30 days so
visit audible.com off the record or text
off the record to 500-500 that's
audible.com off the record or text off
the record to 500-500 to try audible for
free for 30 days audible.com off the
record do you think it's because they
want to be accepted they want to be
president
oh it's people pleasing yeah yeah i just
smell insecurity though so what does
that come off as to you is like lack of
confidence because you're not like you
have to try harder
a little bit of arrogance and
entitlement and i think that
removing those
being just a normal human being and
building rapport with that person is
going to go a lot further then lead with
that lead with that
be friends you know what's interesting
though
there's definitely also girls out there
that like fall for name dropping oh yeah
yeah and there's also like uh not just
girls but in people in general that like
they do get impressed they do get
uh
you know i don't say like a rouser turn
on right away but like that keys them
into the conversation you know what i
mean
maybe some people don't have the game to
uh be charismatic enough with nothing
and work from there maybe uh being able
to be be able to spit like hot fire into
like the first 30 seconds and throw
something might be interesting it's kind
of their only tactic so when it works
once or twice that might be the only
fallback that they have you know i mean
i don't have a problem with somebody
having a conversation about their
experiences with success
and then as and it's relevant to the
conversation i have a problem with
somebody like coming up to me like you
know brad pitt i do
like it's just one of those i'm in
though
imagine she got turned off but the guy
was just telling the truth she's like
who dropped you off oh it was keanu and
she goes what a turn off
she goes i have a boyfriend
he's not he's my brother
he's my brother my last name is
no i really i really did
right imagine how many times that has
happened i know i'm just like this town
in this town just like by default in my
nature i'm like [ __ ] it
oh my god yeah you know keanu reeves
took a [ __ ] in my bathroom one time
uh other oh yeah in real life oh that
did uh other version of the question
that makes you more valuable that you
know him when somebody is fishing he sat
on my toilet
[Laughter]
when someone is fishing for you what is
something that works
um
authenticity
like just being genuine ninety percent
of our followers are like i don't
[ __ ] know what that is you know why
do i do that i think people people don't
know how to be themselves
so that's why they don't know what off
be authentic is so they have to peacock
in front of others male or female to
feel accepted it took me a while to
understand because some of these things
were like really weird to me when i
would hear these cliches of like
just be yourself
be this but then if you don't know who
yourself is
then you have to construct that person
or that ideal person or if you don't
have a sense of security of who you are
because all of this is just ideas of
parents or rules of what other people
told you to be
then it's kind of like oh [ __ ] well
that's where all of my insecurities and
lack of confidence come from is i don't
have this identity so then that whole
journey i think
when i had to go through that i was like
okay that's what being yourself means
and being comfortable and just having
confidence and women like that and i was
like okay that makes a lot of sense
you're a good example of being yourself
though
like
you're really authentic
that sounds more like an insider oh my
god
like you don't even care how you look
man
um for an example like
for the be yourself right um find
something that you're passionate about
and then go do that thing you'll find
other people who are also passionate
about that and then you have rapport you
can already talk about that thing that
you guys are both passionate about and
now it's easier for you to be authentic
and genuine um
yeah effort [ __ ] it okay here we go i'm
gonna tell you something that's very
surprising okay
and you might be like wow i can't
believe this [ __ ] but um
i actually have no game at all no game i
don't i don't believe that
what is game what are you guys waiting
for
because game is always like declared as
this like anti-game is also game so
i have no
life right now by saying that actually i
don't have lines
i don't have anything prepared i don't
have a method i don't know
like a strategy
i don't have any of that the best way is
to shoot the [ __ ] though like you said
like being that's awesome
all i know how to do is make friends and
sexual propositions
but that's why that's why you leap from
the front though you know are you are
you saying we'd be surprised because we
thought you had hell again yeah see yep
yep
i thought you guys would be shocked like
oh my god i thought you were the most
romantic guy in the whole room i'm a
little shocked yeah you kind of remember
i know but then i'm sorry to let you
down bro like i am no recourse you can
never let me know
what do you think about like you know
like pickup artist type people always
say to be mysterious like neil strauss
what does that mean like what about does
that matter if someone's mysterious
if instead of name dropping they go
i don't know anybody
i don't even know who dropped me off
i don't even know the [ __ ] that was
what do you do for a living i don't know
if i'd have so many questions about like
their current state of affairs that that
would engage in a conversation okay so
it's good for initial interest but maybe
not long term
i don't even know how many fingers i
have to be honest
hands your pockets
never seen them scout's honor
what about the age old
what about the age-old you walk into you
know a barn somebody's trying to like
hit on you or something like that and
they're like hey can i buy you a drink
and that's like one of their first lines
okay
sure buy me a drink
okay and then you and then you get it
that's as far as he's gone that's all
he's like and then i'm like hey what
next yeah he's like sure buy me a drink
i gotta use the bathroom
oh i gotta go here's your drink bye
and then i hand that drink to my
boyfriend
free drinks goodbye
i guess goodbye advice is don't buy
people drinks
they will take advantage of it where's
that where's the advice you gotta have a
really good second act right everybody
what's the follow-up you buy the drink
and then what's your conversation all
right that was 17.50
there was a time in my life though where
i felt that
it was much easier and more comfortable
to get into a fist fight than
to walk up to a beautiful woman and try
to talk to her oh dude i know what you
mean that's why you peacock with a
fistfight you were right i understand
that though because what's the worst
that could happen she just says no
you're in the same position
what is the worst that you've done to
someone else that was like just i know
but i think your heart is you know what
it's not even the consequence
because i'm pretty sure it will be no
right like his anticipation is all that
it could be devastating
but i think just
to me it's not even the consequence or
like not of getting it or whatever to me
to even try it is scary
because uh
it's much easier if it's like oh someone
in the friend group or like maybe
you know but to just
try to seal the deal that moment then
and there it's [ __ ] scary as a cold
call like where it's like you don't know
yeah and then you and then so you know
that right so like you and your friends
do it as a team like remember when you
go to the mall and everyone went to the
mall right and everyone like back in the
day junior high high school you get
dropped off at the mall you would see
other girls and just be like are you
going dude no i'll do it this time all
right let's go you know and you go up
you're like man this one's too cute it's
so scary i think you also give women too
much leverage and value like you're
already going into it thinking that
she's up here and you're here
that's the leverage that's a bad thing
too and so it's like instead of coming
at it from that angle like coming the
other angle she's down here
what's up
yeah the celebrity might tell you [ __ ]
off but it's so scary because you want
to just say hi can we take a picture you
know
that's so sad though like if a woman
says like if you're genuine you come up
in a nice way and she says [ __ ] off yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] then you go you're ugly
anyway and then
[Laughter]
that's how you make people i didn't even
like you anyways takes the drink back
yeah you have too many split ends anyway
it was all a social experiment yeah your
eyelashes are not even on one side [ __ ]
you
by the way you're on camera with ashley
kushner
stupid that's kind of what's missing of
i don't know if like kids do it right
but in high school and junior high
that's what we did we go to the mall
we're like okay group of pretty girls
let's just try to talk to them and you
go hey what's up and then it's like you
use those stupid lines like hey
if he was a book i'd pick you
fire and you're like what 13 trying to
do some stupid [ __ ] like that and you
know
can i get your pager number or whatever
and then like you get the number and
then later on you [ __ ] call and then
that's when you start feeling like okay
let's talk let's flirt you know yeah
yeah but then in that moment though like
that that feeling is so scary because i
think for for me it was the ambiguity
because when you're like young and you
don't have a lot of experience you're
not really sure where you stand on the
scale of attractiveness until it's it
comes to practice so then you see a girl
and you're like she's hot am i
hot like that where i go up to her and
she'll be interested or where do i stand
like are we a match yeah so it's hard
it's hard to like face that maybe you're
not because
i realize that she also doesn't know
what the hell she's doing either yeah
that's too young though yeah that's too
young
we are stupid i mean women like type
like typically have more practice than
men because they get approached more
often than men yeah so like there's that
um sorry for yourself i know i get
approached all the time i first met
first by men
yeah yeah by the police officers
i actually first found that i felt that
um maybe when i was like
freshman year or like junior high
my last year junior high i forgot how i
got into this situation but there was
like
um like one of the hottest chicks in
school nice dude no no nothing happened
already
nothing
and i think we were we were all kind of
in a in a similar friend group right
and then uh we're on a similar friend
group i don't know how this happened but
it ended up being
me and her uh just like walking back
from school together i don't know how
that happened
and she was one of those chicks where it
was like in your mind she's untouchable
she it's like either like
that dude who is gonna like go to the
nfl and talk to her or that dude whose
older brother's in prison is going to
talk to her
i you know it's like one of those things
and i was walking home with her and
we're just talking
to the point where like after i think we
got to the street we're supposed to
split she was like asking me like if
we're gonna hang out some other other
time or whatever and uh we're hanging
out i was like
get this though no i just froze i didn't
even know what to say right oh yeah yeah
yeah i was trying to play it cool
and the whole time i just couldn't even
believe that i talked to like a [ __ ]
angel like that
when bartenders pulled his eyelids back
that's like some real [ __ ] i was like
whoa dude let me tell you what the [ __ ]
i couldn't even believe what happened
and uh i was so like
um excited to see what would happen
after but i ended up getting kicked out
of school so would nothing happen after
that but i was just like that's what i
realized that's what i realized like it
doesn't really matter where you are or
who or whatever like that it's if people
can connect on something there's some
sort of rapport that'll happen and then
people want you back and when you feel
that energy then it's like fire okay so
has a woman ever hit on you and did you
like that experience and how did she do
it
there was a chicken it's so quiet
it's never i was waiting for his answer
so in junior high
this is my favorite story there's a
chick that told me
um do you remember this is this so
[ __ ] dumb but like you remember um op
talk or yap talk or something where
instead of saying [ __ ] because it's like
cody you want other people to to say
it's like let's see if i say toy you'll
say top up
yap so it's like t-o-p it's like similar
to like w g okay yeah yeah all right so
me and this chick were talking on the
phone pig latin and my brain already i
already friendzoned her yeah right
so my brain already friends on there and
then we were talking about like who we
thought were cute whatever and then she
said you like yap oh you
and then
uh
i hung up on her awesome
[Laughter]
because on her side she's probably like
damn i've been rejected and just like
the trauma from
[Laughter]
he just freaked out what if that was her
first this food just freaked out sorry
esther she's still traumatized
wow what about you guys i think i think
we're out of time he has to go
and they got too many stories bro
anthony tell yours as you walk out
yeah um nah
you